اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري ونتابع اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه معك محمود الكن
تفضل محمود ا نعم ليلى هناك تطورات كثيره
حدثت هذا اليوم في شمال القطاع وجنوبه لكن
دعيني ابدا بدايه من الجنوب هنا اذا ما
توجهنا الى جنوب قطاع غزه تحديدا في خان
يونس المعارك كانت ضاريه في شرق هذه
المناطق المناطق باللون الاصفر هي مناطق
التوغل الاسرائيلي وليس السيطره وسنتحدث
عن هذا مره اخرى بعد قليل لكن سنشاهد هنا
في هذا ال في هذه المنطقه كان هناك
استهداف ل مجموعه من الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
باستخدام قذائف الياس
ايضا قامت المقاومه الفلسطينيه وذكرت
بانها استهدف استهدفت مجموعه متحصنه من
الجنود الاسرائيليين في مبان هنا ما ادى
كانوا متحصنين ما ادى الى اصابه ومقتل نحو
عره جنود هذا بالنسبه ل خان يونس وشرق خان
يونس اذا ما توجهنا الان اذا الى المنطقه
الشماليه ايضا نشاهد مناطق التوغل
الاسرائيلي بال اللون الاصفر هنا ما تزال
المعارك ضاريه جدا في الشجاعيه محاولات
الدفع الاسرائليه بهذا الاتجاه ايضا كان
هناك استهداف من قبل مقاومه اي
ل توغل اسرائيلي كان موجودا في جنوب حي
الزيتون ما تزال القوات الاسرائيليه تغير
بشكل كبير على جباليا ومخيم جباليا وكنا
نستمع الى شبكه مراسلين تتحدث عن كثافه
هذه الغارات هناك لكن لماذا جباليا ومخيم
جباليا نشاهد ايضا اللون الاصفر يفسر ذلك
محاوله تطويق مستمره منذ
اي منذ المرحله الثانيه بدايه المرحله
الثانيه من العمليات العسكريه لاغلاق هذه
الفجوه لكن هذا لم يتم حتى هذه اللحظه رغم
الاعلانات العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي قالت
انه تم تطويقه في السابق في الكامل لكن
دوما نتذكر اللون الاصفر دوما نتذكر
التوغل وليس السيطره لماذا هذا الاعلان
الاسرائيلي
هنا عن اكتشاف نفق في شمال قطاع غزه
تحديدا في معبر ارز في هذه
المنطقه هنا وهذه هي الخريطه التي نشرها
الجيش الاسرائيلي وبان النفق يصل الى هنا
لكن دعونا نراه مره اخرى على الخريطه بشكل
تقريبي هذا هو اذا ما شاهدناه على الخريطه
اللون الاصفر معبر ارز القوات الاسرائيليه
كانت قد توغلت منذ اليوم الاول من العمليه
البريه بدايه النفق او نهايته هو في هذه
النقطه نحو 40 متر فقط عن السياج الحدودي
حوالي
350 متر الى هذه النقطه يعني منتصف معبر
ارس بالتالي نحن نتحدث عن قوات كانت قد
توغلت منذ اكثر من خ 4 يوما
وا اعلن عن هذا الاكتشاف انه اذا ما
شاهدنا وطابق الصور التي نشرها الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو قال انها 4 كيلومترات لكن
صوره المخطط تشير الى نحو كر و2 متر وه
يبعد فقط 40 مت عن السياج الحدودي تشاهدون
اللون الاصفر منطقه توغل الاسرائيلي كانت
منذ بدايه الحرب خاصه في الشمال كنا نتحدث
عن المناطق الزراعيه المفتوحه هنا كانت
مناطق ارتكاز للمدرعات اذا لماذا يتم
الاعلان عن هذا اليوم كيف تم اكتشاف مثل
هذا النفق الكبير الذي تمر فيه الاليات
اليوم المزيد من هذه الاسئله معكما ليلى
واللواء فايز بالفعل محمود لماذا تم
الاعلان عن النفق اليوم لواء فايز خصوصا
ان الفتحه يفترض انها موجوده في مكان كانت
القوات الاسرائيليه موجوده فيه من اليوم
الاول تحديدا من منذ 47 يوما فلماذا يعلن
الان يعني الان متى تم اكتشافه هذا يعود
الى الجانب الاسرائيلي يعني لا نستطيع ان
نقول ان اكتشفه هذا اليوم او اكتشفه قبل
هذا اليوم انما هو اعلن في هذا اليوم حتى
نكون ملتزمين جانب الحياد التام في
التحليل هو اعلن انه اكتشفه هذا اليوم هل
اكتشف قبل ام لم
يكتشفوا لا نستطيع ان ان نحدد ولكن السؤال
الاعلان بحد ذاته ايضا لماذا اعلن في هذا
اليوم اكتشافه لا نعلم متى لكن لماذا
الاعلان اعتقد ان الاعلان اولا يخدم اكثر
من من بعد تعثر العمليات في منطقه جباليا
ومخيم جباليا ويقول بانه طوله 4 ك متر يصل
الى منطقه جباليا اذا يعني جباليه كاسم
ذكر في الاعلان هذا التعثر يحتاج الى مبرر
بعد مقتل الرهائن
بعد افلام القسام المبرر انه احن نواجه
تحدي
ومتحدث قال صراحه نواجه ظرف لم يواجهنا من
قبل يعني نواجه ظروف ميدانيه معقده الان
يريد ان يدعم وجهه هذا النظر فجاء الاعلان
عن هذا النفق يعني بمعنى انه احتاج ان
يقدم شيء ربما للداخل الاسرا رر يبرر فشل
الفشل في تطور ونجاح وتقدم العمليات يعني
اذا الشيء بالشيء اذا تحدثنا عن الخارطه
الخارطه قال محمود الفالوجه هو دخلها قبل
مع بدايه قبل الهدنه ودخلها بعد الهدنه
واخرج منها وهي خارج تواجده وليس سيطرته
اذا هو بحاجه ان يقدم شيء الان هذا النفق
عندما يعلن عنه نعم تم نشر هذه الصور
السؤال المطروح من وجهه نظر عسكريه
تحليليه بحته هل لو هذا النفق يخدم
العمليات الاسرائيليه القادمه هل يمكن ان
يعلن عنه هل يعلن انه اكتشفه ويصوره لا
اعتقد ذلك المنطق يقول لو هذا النفق سيخدم
العمليات اللاحقه لا يمكن الاعلان عنه
خاصه انه اعلن عن نفق طوله 4 ك مر
كشف منه في الخارطه تقريبا 1250 حسب رسم
الخارطه الى 1400 متر والباقي لم يكشفوا
بعد يعني كانه قدم المعلومه على طبق من
ذهب لقوات المقاومه ليتخذوا اجراء ما وهذا
الشيء يعني هل هو واقعي ان يفعله هذا غ
هذا غير منطقي الا في حاله واحده ان هذا
النفق له بدايه ونهايه ولا ينفتح على شبكه
الانفاق وقد
طريق مسدود ن مسدود نعم ضدد وقد يكون
الاحتمال من ضمن الافتراضات ان فتحه النفق
ليست داخل غزه داخل غلاف غزه ولكنه لا يود
ان يقول ذلك تحوطا لامور مستقبليه السؤال
كيف تم الوصول الى معبر ايرس في المره
الثانيه في المره الاولى عبر السياج
والمره الثانيه نحن لا نعلم هل كان هذا
النفق هو الذي افضى
الى الى موقع ايرز سؤال لا املك اجابته
هذا تملك اجابته القوات الاسرائيليه التي
كانت متواجده في
هذه دعيني اقول اولا موعد الاعلان مرتبط
بتعثر العمليات العسكريه والاعلان لا
اعتقد انه يضر بسريه شبكه الانفاق لانه لو
كان يضر بذلك لن يعلن لانه يجب ان يستفيد
لا يمكن يمكن ان يقدم المعلومه لانه سيكون
لدى قسم الهندسه في في القسام الاجراء
الفوري الاني لو كان هذا النفق يوصل الى
ما بعده لتم قطعه واغلاقه وبالتالي هذه
المعلومه يعني قدمت اعتقد من مقاربه
لرساله داخليه اكثر
منها رساله حه جدا وطبعا سنرى التداعيات
خلال الفتره القادمه فقط ايضا لنتكلم عن
عن هذا الفيديو الذي يوضح غارات على غلاف
غزه كما نشاهد الان الان الغلاف غزه هو
كان كان هناك حديث طفى الى السطح تقريبا
قبل ثلاثه اسابيع وحتى قبل اندلاع للموجه
الثانيه وك وقرات في بعض التقارير ان جيش
الاحتلال يهدف الى السيطره شبه الكامله
على المنطقه الزراعيه وهي المنطقه الواقعه
بين السياج وبين ال
بدايه المناطق المبنيه وكان هناك توجه
لحفر خندق ضد الدبابات عميق و جعل ساتر
ترابي في الجهه ساتر ترابي في الجهه
الشرقيه من الخندق ليحول ليكون ليحول دون
الرصد القريب الارضي المباشر ويؤمن نوع من
الحمايه للقوات الاسرائيليه التي ستبقى في
هذه المنطقه الان عمليه التدمير الم ممنهج
ل لكافه المناطق المبنيه المطله على
الاراضي الزراعيه هو يعتقد انه اذا عمل
بذلك يحول دون وجود قناصين او يمنع من
امكانيه المراقبه ولكنها تاتي ضمن اطار
التدمير الممنهج لغزه وليس لهذه المنطقه
وربما تستعمل المروحيات لا ادري اذا كانت
اي هذه صوره المروحيات التي تستخدم ل هذ
هذه و وهي زودت ب بنوعين صواريخ سبايك
وصواريخ هيلفاير وهذه اول لقطه للطائرات
تزود ب نوعين من الصواريخ في نفس الوقت
تحمل 16 صاروخ سبايك اذا ما كان بصوره
منفرده وهو متطور اكثر من هلف اذا سمحت لي
لواء فايز نتكلم قليلا عن لواء جولاني هذا
اللي اثير شيء من اللغط عنه ان رئيس
اللواء تحدث عن فقدان ربع من قوته ثم تمت
التوضيح انه 10% من
القوه ككل ولكن الربع مقصود به الكتيبه
التي دخلت الشجاعيه الان هذا اللواء
تنظيمه مرن ليس
تنظيما مثبتا كبقيه التشكيلات هذا اسس في
عام 48 وهو نسبه الى منطقه الجليل وليس
الى الجولان كما يعتقد الب لا الجولان
احتلت في 67 هذا اسس 488 نسبه الى الجليل
وهو يتب على المنطقه الشماليه و تنظيمه
مختلف حتى عندما تبحثي عن تنظيمه ستجديه
من فتره الى فتره مختلف اخر تنظيم له كان
يحتوي على هو ملتحقين معظمهم من الاحتياط
ومن طلاب المدارس الدينيه يكون لهم تدريب
مخصص وتدريب مكثف ولمده تسعه اشهر في
المرحله الاولى ثم يتبعوا ت ووظف في 2014
في الشجاعيه تحدي تنظيمه بصوره عامه في
اقصى حالات
يصل الى ثمانيه كتائب اربعه كتائب دبابات
كتيبتي مشاه كتيبه مدفعيه واسلحه الاسناد
من الهندسه واللاسلكي والخدمات الاداريه
والخدمات الطبيه هذا زج به في عام 2014
وواجه مقاومه شرسه منه شرسه من المقاتلين
وبلغت لها حوالي في بعض التقارير وقد
تختلف الى 70 واحد قائد الكتيب الذي قتل
الاول هو قتل قاده الكتيب واستبدل ثم قتل
الثاني قاد الكتيب الاول الذي قتل كان له
فيديو كان يحث جنوده على مزيد من القتل
والثار لعام 2014 فوقع في مصده الشجاعيه
مره مره ثانيه ويقال بانه في في هذا
الصباح تحدثوا عن 25% ثم عادوا فتحدثوا عن
10% من اجمال القوه المتورطه في القتال
طيب ايضا مهم جدا ان اتكلم عن الوضع في
خان يونس تحديدا اليوم الوض الوضع في خان
يونس الان ال الهجوم من اتجاهين من اتجاه
كشفين القراره والمطاحن
الى السجن الى مشروع او ابراج حمد و عمليه
اخلاء جوي حصلت اليوم هذه في القراره تم
تدمير اليتين نمر ويبدو ان الاصابات كانت
اصابات قاتله
نعم هي اصابات قاتر واصابات ادت الى
اصابات حرجه فكان لا بد من ارسال طائره
لنقلهم الى اق الى اقر الى اقر مستشفى
الان الهجوم هذا الهجوم الشمالي الهجوم
الجنوبي اخذ قاعده اعرض في منطقه بني سيلا
وعبس الصغرى وعبس الكبرى الان هم يقاتلوا
في بني سيلا ولم ولم يقطعوا شارع صلاح
الدين باتجاه خان يونس كنت تتحدث عن بغداد
شارع بغداد اللي ايضا قاطع مع في الشجاعيه
كنا نتمنى ان نتطرق الى هذه النقطه ولكن
وصلنا الى ختام هذه الفقره شكرا جزيلا لك
اللواء فايز الدويري